Hello and welcome to the last video in about interfaces.
And in this, I'm just going to be going into a little bit more detail about the play option
in the editor.
Okay, so here we are back in the editor, and I have added in three cubes, which are set
to rotate.
Don't worry about too much about how I've done it.
It's just so that we can see when the game is running and when it is not.
Now what I want to look at is the different play options that we have.
So you can see up here with our standard play, if we were to hit normal play, here would
default at the moment to playing it within the editor window.
Now I could push F11 to make this full screen.
That's fine, it just runs within the editor window.
Now if I press escape, that's going to bring me out of it.
Now it's set to play an editor, but we have a couple of options.
So first option that we have is still play an editor, and that's what play means, but
it will do it in a separate window.
And this is useful if you want it running, so that you can make changes next to it.
It's exactly the same thing.
And again, escape will let you come out of it.
And you'll see that this has now changed the default to be playing a new window.
As we swap between the models, they will sit as a default.
The next one that I want to look at is a standalone game.
And this is interesting because what it does is it fires up as if it was a compiled packaged
game.
Now it obviously won't be as compiled as if it had gone through the packaging, but you
can see it had to load the shaders there.
And this runs independently.
Now in this case, escape will not work, because that's an editor function.
Escape within the actual game is going to be something you'd have to code in yourself.
So I'm just going to manually kill it.
Now the final option I want you to be aware of is called simulate.
And what simulate does is it will not spawn the pawn that you have attached to the game.
It'll actually spawn something called a spectator pawn.
And this is going to allow you to move around the world and see how the games function it.
So if you have things like NPCs, they would run around, but it'll allow you to just check
and see what's going on without having to be spawned as a character.
And that's really useful.
You'll also have this option here where you can press F8.
All that it's going to do is that's going to now spawn the character and allow you to
move around.
So those are your main options.
So just to clarify that, we have a number of options here.
You have the selected viewport, which is the default one.
The new editor window is going to create a new editor window and still allow you to see
this viewport behind it.
Standalone game, which runs it as a separate app.
And finally, we have simulate, which will play in the editor with a spectator pawn for
free movement.
Also, I just want to iterate some of the hotkeys.
If you press Alt plus P, it will start the play mode that you have selected.
Here in time.
If you press F8, it will switch between the spectator pawn and the player pawn.
And finally, escape is going to end.
This will only work in the editor play modes.
And with that, that will bring us to the end of the interface sections.
We can now move on to have a look at importing assets into Unreal.